[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le pea paris-saclay s'inscrit dans la
trajectoire national de neutralité
carbone à horizon 2050 et pour cela
s'engage dans la construction bio
sourcés et la construction durable pour
cela nous avons signés fin 2020 le pacte
bois bio sourcés lancé par la filière
bois ile de france et nous nous sommes
engagés à réaliser d'ici 2024
40% à minima les surfaces de plancher en
structure bois ou en matériaux
biosourcés cet engagement il se décline
concrètement sur toutes les opérations
de l'opéra paris saclay et il prévoit
que seront construites près de 300 mille
mètres carrés de surface de plancher en
matériaux biosourcés notamment en
structure bois nous travaillons beaucoup
sur l'intégration des matériaux
biosourcés et du bois en structures de
bâtiments et sur la mixité des matériaux
et c'est dans ce cadre que vous avez
derrière nous le loup est sain de la
hacker house qui est une des premières
réalisations concrètes de le pea en
structure bois
c'est un bâtiment de sept niveaux donc
rez-de-chaussée plus six étages c'était
une résidence étudiante qui est composé
de onze type au logis de logements qui
va du studio jusqu'à la coloc de six
personnes donc une grande variété de
l'aménagement des logements donc on a un
socle en béton s'adresse à la ville et
ensuite six niveaux construits en bois
l'avantagent de la construction voit
c'est la rapidité d'exécution sur le
chantier par exemple les six niveaux ont
été montées en un peu plus de trois mois
et cela est possible grâce à une grande
préfabrication en usine donc toutes les
façades par exemple sont préfabriqués le
plancher les ossatures le poteau poutre
également et tout est assemblé sur sur
le chantier donc il n'ya pas de retour
je suis très peu de retouches à faire
cette résidence de calling répond à de
fortes exigences environnementales qui
avait été souhaité par la ville de
palaiseau est également l'établissement
public de paris saclay
le principe de la construction bois va
nous permettre de réaliser cette
opération dans des délais
rapides et surtout de permettre
l'arrivée des étudiants dès la rentrée
universitaire 2022 ce qui est absolument
essentiel pour le territoire pour
pouvoir renforcer encore davantage son
besoin d'accueil des étudiants